Now let's look at these calls and try to figure out what the dependencies are among them.
First and most obviously, nothing is going to succeed,
no file system call is going to succeed, until we've mounted the file system.
Similarly, no file system call will succeed after we've unmounted it.
So we want to be careful with mount and unmount.
We don't want to just freely mix those into our stream of random API calls that we're making
because if we do that, we're going to be mounting and unmounting the thing so often
that the file system code is never going to get into the kind of steady state
that we're going to need it to be in in order to do effective random testing of it.
So similarly, some of the other calls in a file system, like reading and writing to a file,
are only going to succeed if the file has been opened.
And so if we do something silly like providing completely random arguments
to open read and write, then the odds of us actually successfully reading or writing
to an open file are going to be extremely low.
So we're going to have to do something more systematic.
We're probably going to have to do something like open a file
and keep track of the fact that it's open
so we can randomly generate read and write calls into it.
There are probably some other dependencies as well.
So what we're seeing is that if we want to do effective random testing of a file system,
we're going to need to track these dependencies,
at least in some rudimentary fashion, in order to issue a sequence of API calls
that's going to do reasonably effective random testing of a file system.
The second issue that starts to come up as we perform random testing of APIs
is that our tests--that is to say, a sequence of file system operations in this example--
are going to become quite large, and that's going to beg the question,
how are those tests represented?
In the examples we've seen so far,
test cases haven't had any sort of official existence of their own.
What we've rather done is mix the software under test
and the test driver code in a single piece of Python code.
So now if we do this, what's the actual form taken by the test cases?
And the answer has to be that those test cases only exist as ephemeral objects in memory.
For most testing purposes, that's fine.
The driver code creates the test cases, passes them to the software under test,
looks at the results, and keeps going until it finishes.
There are a couple cases in which that's not so good.
One of them is where we find a particular test case that makes our system fail
and we'd like to save off that test case for later use in regression testing.
And so what we end up having to do to make that work is writing some separate code
which also lives in the Python program to load and save test cases.
And so now this module is going to be doing file AO in order to load and save test cases,
and most likely those test cases are going to be saved as text files or something.
So for example, if we wanted to represent a sequence of file system calls as a text file,
we could just have the word mkdir followed by whatever the arguments to mkdir are,
and then the loading and saving code would need to either parse those files
in order to create a test case in memory or unparse them--
that is to say, pretty print them to disk in order to save a test case.
And so there's a couple advantages of doing this.
First of all, as I was saying, it facilitates regression testing.
And the second reason is that it's often the case
that when random tests become extremely large,
we need to turn them into first class objects--that is to say, objects living on disk
using some sort of a save and load routine--in order to perform test case reduction.
Test case reduction is a piece of technology that's very often combined with random testing,
and what it is and what it does is takes a large test case
that makes the software under test fail and turns it into a smaller test case
that still makes the software under test fail.
We'll look at more detail and we'll look at test case reduction in more detail
later on in this course. Now what I'd like to do...